so here's here's what I want to say  because um right now there's a lot of  stories you know uh Trump is being told  that he's got to denounce these guys  there was a story that popped up on Fox  Fox 5 Kanye West spotted in Frederick  after storming off of podcast  here's the potential scenario to be fair  the scenario is they abruptly left the  show they were on it yay didn't like  that I was not agreeing with him or that  I was pushing back in any capacity got  up and stormed off Milo and Nick working  for yay wouldn't stick around and left  immediately they called a charter  company to schedule a private plane who  was very very they were very lucky that  a hot crew it's what they're on the  ground ready to go was available nearby  and was able to then dispatch a plane to  Frederick that they could then get into  within a couple hours notice entirely  possible my personal opinion  that sounds really really crazy if  that's the case